Україна посіла 60 місце серед 180 країн світу,
згідно з останнім Індексом екологічної ефективності.
Вона пасе задніх серед європейських країн.
Що це за індекс і чому це важливо?
Environmental Performance Index або просто EPI  -
це глобальний аналіз екологічної ефективності країн,
який проводить Єльський університет разом з Колумбійським
та Всесвітнім економічним форумом
Результати оприлюднюються раз на два роки.
Досліджуються 32 показники в 11 категоріях.
Зокрема якість повітря та питної води, зміна клімату, біорізноманіття.
Цей індекс дозволяє зрозуміти стан навколишнього середовища,
здоров’я населення та державної політики в сфері екології кожної конкретної країни.
Україна нині знаходиться між Венесуелою та Уругваєм на 60 місці.
Усі європейські країни попереду, окрім Молдови, Грузії та трьох балканських держав.
Одні з найгірших даних в категорії "якість повітря"
за показником ризиків для здоров’я від впливу дрібнодисперсного пилу.
Він не відразу осідає на землю, а залишається деякий час в атмосфері.
Частинки цього пилу настільки дрібні, що потрапляють у легені,
а потім у судини і дуже шкодять здоров’ю.
Від цієї невидимої загрози найбільше потерпають у великих мегаполісах,
зокрема через викиди автомобілів та промислових підприємств.
А найбільше в Україні "просідає" категорія "біорізноманіття".
За даними розробниківІндексу екологічної ефективності,
країна мало робить для збереження природних екосистем
та захисту рослин і тварин, які там мешкають.
Як наслідок, біорізноманіття зменшується, а території деградують.
А очолює рейтинг найбільш "зелених" країн світу
за екологічною ефективністю Данія.
Майже все сміття в країні переробляється.
На даху сміттєспалювального заводу в Копенгагені
навіть зробили гірськолижний спуск, на якому можна кататися навіть улітку.
Данія - серед лідерів у виконанні зобов’язань щодо збереження клімату,
вона планує скоротити на 70%
викиди CO2 вже до 2030 року
і впродовж цього десятиріччя повністю відмовитися від вугілля.
Услід за Данією другу і третю сходинки рейтингу
посідають Люксембург та Швейцарія.
Серед лідерів також традиційно скандинавські країни.
Приміром, Швеція заповзялася за 20 років
100-відсотково перейти на відновлювані джерела енергії.
Промислова Німеччина посідає 10-те місце.
До кінця 2022 року країна хоче закрити всі атомні електростанції,
а до 2038 - відмовитися від вугілля.
Країни-сусіди випереджають Україну:
Польща - на 37-й, Білорусь - на 49-й і Росія - на 58-й позиції.
Дослідники сподіваються, що пандемія коронавірусу
змусить уряди багатьох країн замислитися над своєю екологічною політикою,
і планета стане чистішою.